Pakistan has a new Army Chief now
ordinarily such an appointment is a
routine feature but not in Pakistan
where the military has ruled the country
for nearly half of its 75-year history
Asim munir has been named to the top job
by prime minister Shahbaz Sharif after
several days of nail biting speculation
that's because munir takes over at a
time of increased political instability
in the country former prime minister
Imran Khan is demanding early elections
and blaming the military for not only
having a hand in his ouster from
government but also in a later
assassination attempt on him
so what does the new appointment mean
for Pakistan to help us understand I'm
joined by DW reporter binish Javed in
studio finish welcome why was this
appointment proving so controversial
British Pakistan military is one
considered to be one of the most it
actually is the most powerful
institution in the country with huge
influence in politics so anytime the
Army Chief has disappointed it's a very
important decision but this became
hugely controversial this time because
when Imran Khan Pakistan's former prime
minister he was ousted on through a no
confidence vote this April
um he directly blamed the military
of colluding with his political
opponents at that time and the U.S and
since he was ousted he led a very
aggressive campaign against the military
directly accusing them of isolating him
um and and and he further went on saying
that the government the current
government is not legitimate and any
appointment the current government makes
of the new military Chief will be
controversial let's talk about Imran
Khan and these rallies I mean he's
proving very popular there's hundreds of
thousands of people who are attending
the Israelis how is this putting
pressure on the government so since
people in rallies he has held rallies
across Pakistan and the Israelis means
that cities shut so it's a big headache
for the government and at the Israelis
Imran Khan calls the current government
for instance the Prime Minister the
interior Minister corrupt
um and and and and and he has been not
giving any breathing space to the
government through these rallies and he
constantly asks for an early election he
believes that he has the political
momentum he has people support and if
there is an early election then he can
win and this is what he really wants
from the government and the government
is also has so far not shown any
flexibility now you also have Imran Khan
promising a rally in rawal Pindi
around the same time that this
announcement has been made this new Army
Chief has been appointed what is Imran
Khan trying to do with this is he trying
to challenge the Army in any way Imran
Khan has challenged a tree like no other
politician in Pakistan has done so since
he was ousted
in these rallies he accuses the military
of buying out his members he accuses the
military of influencing the legislation
of uh of controlling the media and and
these allegations sometimes made the
military to defend themselves and to
come out and and and give statements uh
to defend themselves so I think what
Imran Khan is doing
um I have not seen such an attack on the
military and such a powerful attack that
it it really the military had to come
out and defend themselves so now that we
have a new Army Chief will this provide
some stability to Pakistan I think it's
really difficult to say what will happen
in Pakistan uh anything can happen but I
there is a hope that there is um with
the appointment because Imran Khan was
consulted and although it doesn't make
Imran Khan like really happy with the
decision but it seems like for instance
Imran Khan's political party has
welcomed the decision so it seems that
maybe and there are reports that some
members of the government have spoken to
uh Imran Khan's political party some
members of that as some members of his
party so maybe we hope we uh that you
know there is some diffusion or there's
some partial
um diffusion in the attention very
briefly where do the people stand with
the military do they sign with the
military or they against it so Pakistan
military has been a very respectful
institution in the country uh although
if we look at Pakistan's history in more
than 75 years of its history military
has ruled for more than three decades
and even in the military in the Civil
civilian governments military has
meddled in politics influencing the
Prime Minister on important security
policies important foreign policy
decisions but despite that
despite that people have respected the
military but I think Imran Khan has been
able to damage that image and that
criticism of the military it was
resonated among people so I think that
support the military enjoyed for many
years was damaged finish we'll leave it
there thanks so much for coming in and
breaking that down for us thank you